[Music]
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
experience you guys know the drill
today's episode is sponsored by ring
equip and me undies we have got so many
great things today I don't hear the
music is the music plane oh yeah oh yeah
it is great great great great great
great today we've got such wonderful
things we've got Logan Paul tweet of the
century erased and reborn
we've got Roseanne finally speaking out
and boy you don't want to miss this so
good we have got other and lots of set
we've got another episode of know your
meme giving away a brand new s 9 plus
what what would this time featuring
everybody's favorite virgin Skippy
actually we have a new callin number 2
that I think is really soothing that I
think everyone is gonna really enjoy you
can reach us for now and forevermore at
8:08 hot meme that's eight oh eight hot
meme Mme
as you all know so that's our permanent
number keep it handy guys you can start
ringing in now to play know your meme
after the break featuring everyone's
favorite virgin Skippy eel is back think
God think the gods she is it's a little
too soon for her to hop in front of the
camera so she is and back right now she
is here she's cracking whips was in the
house she is making sure that everybody
is crossing their T's and dot in their
eyes back there they're all in mortal
fear of Elah right now it's true no
[ __ ] around this time but we will be
having a special episode next week on
Tuesday I think what it's just gonna be
me and ela probably just like a
30-minute little app where we can just
kind of talk bring her back
get her back in see how she's doing and
then on Thursday we've got dunkey beta
game donkey and lea gonna be great with
that being said we've got so much to get
to but first
let's start with our goof of the day
let's try and think of a name Vlasic
goof of the day I like the idea when we
do these top of the weeks to start it
every time with a beautiful great little
video that we're all gonna love goof of
the day up first we've got laughter yoga
this video I'm very conflicted about
this video laughter yoga because well
yeah I'll just show you it's like these
people they all have these awful
diseases and their method of coping with
it is by manic laughing and I get it
like I think it's a cool thing but it's
like it's so eerie and strange I mean
let's just start it off right here guys
here we go god bless
diagnosis and we're gonna laugh again
yeah and so you go around the room it's
very powerful now if you don't and we'll
do it just with a few people here just
to get a flavour if anybody has a
diagnosis they want to share and laugh
about that'd be great and if you don't
then what I've done is combine it with
the haha mantra which is you'll say your
name and it happened recently to you
that normally would really bum you out
and share it with us and we'll laugh at
it so it's that whole psychology of you
know turning lemons into lemonade okay
so you guys get it this lady by the way
where do you get that earring I think on
face value it sounds nice but when you
watch it it's like I just don't buy the
laughter it's like the saddest [ __ ] I've
ever seen so here's I'll and I always
start and say here's how it looks so my
name is Geeta the one thing that throws
me off that makes me feel strange about
this is like why laughing after the name
it makes it seem like they're just
clowning yeah that was about trauma look
like they'll a comma
yeah they laugh after they say the
trauma but then like they're like hi my
name is Ethan it's like I feel like you
getting clowned on you're gonna see what
I mean that's that I don't know your
name for chrissake you know what I mean
it's like alright something's not right
and I was diagnosed with Parkinson's
disease
[Laughter]
[Applause]
anybody else wanna share get the idea
that's a strange it's a strange thing
you know very strange I get it you know
I get it it's a nice wholesome thing
they're trying to do here I just I don't
know it's so eerie there's something so
off about it you'll see it gets more
obscene as they go along but I don't get
the whole very good very good yay all
the sudden they're in kindergarten and
that was where they lost me to be honest
yeah I kind of understand it and but
then when the weird like cult chanting
started right it got pretty creepy right
there
yes dawn he took a shot at he took a
shot
you know he put his hand up in class my
name is dawn why you got a goof why you
got a clown on poor dawn
that's so weird I they laugh at their
name it's hard not to see you like them
just laughing at their misfortune
they're not it just I don't see them
like embrace from my perspective I just
acquired insulin resistant diabetes I
don't know I just sounds like they're
clowning on hysterical that's the
funniest [ __ ] I've heard all day
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well are you gonna comment for us Viki
that's the one that got me
I've got breast cancer that's the funny
[ __ ] I've heard all year this woman's
eyes really lit up on that one yeah no
she's like she's like oh [ __ ] the more
tragic the more hilarious my name is
Vicki and I was I was stranded and had
to eat my own son to stay alive it's
like the more tragic the more hilarious
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes I don't buy it I think I just don't
buy it like she's got the happy face
earrings she's got the laughter yoga
she's all smiles but there's like a real
sadness you know what I mean it's like
they're not acknowledged I don't know
what do is healthy no yeah that's what I
don't know I don't know something about
this seems so demented and I don't want
to goof on these people because you know
they're trying to cope with some
difficult stuff just trying to analyze
how I feel about it
let's see maybe the next one is just
like straight up like you know my
husband I'm Dan and I murdered my son
right and I ate his corpse very good
very good yay
[Laughter]
oh I didn't even let her like they cut
they kind of cut her off they did like
an Academy Award on her that's like I
was developed with MS 19 years ago it's
like alright [ __ ] tone it down it's old
news it's not good it's also like I
didn't give you permission to expand you
have MS move on to the next person we're
all [ __ ] dying here my name is uh hi
guys my name is Ethan and my anal
sphincter muscle has stopped operating
and I'm perpetually [ __ ] my pants
that's really not that tragic compared
to what they're doing with what's you
know let's see how we're good whoa what
was that let me go back got that got a
huge lot is it just that she's over but
you need to leave doesn't qualify for
yoga laughter by the way she wasn't like
oh I'm overweight I'm morbidly
overweight she's like some people think
people get the [ __ ] you know what you
get a bill
and you get crickets we got breast
cancer we got MS you know to be here all
over wait shut the [ __ ] up I'm a little
overweight yeah wouldn't be graved she
was just like you know what stop
everyone stop laughing [ __ ] get out she
just actually laughing now she's like
this isn't laughs yoga I'm laughing at
you why would you need a group council
just because you're some people think
you're overweight give it up you you you
were you're in a different room
sometimes you get scared of running out
of money you and the fat lady need to go
start your own laughter yoga okay what
what
don't worry whatever for you and
everybody dude yeah chuckle at best you
don't deserve the laughs if I'm being
Frank and chuckle yoga anyway I'm not
sure how to make of all this stuff it's
like I know they're they're desperately
trying to cope with really awful and
unimaginable things but it's like it's
just so eerie and strange to see these
things side by side and I'm dying of
breast cancer yeah
anyway I have one other goof of the day
that I wanted to watch with you guys the
pedo lizard today it's goofs of the day
today my friend well this the story is
that this video was used to be shown to
middle schoolers back in the 90s to help
inform them about I guess this is one
like the pedophile scare started when
every random male specifically males was
looking to abduct you so this this
little short here was meant to educate
define innocent young children of
America and to avoiding being taken so
here I give you the pedo hunting
dinosaur bro I'm gonna tell you straight
up if there's any pedophile it's in that
[ __ ] suit listen to that voice man
and I'll tell you what else there's
enough space in that suit for a man and
a child like he could he could be like
climbing my suit young one hi there whoa
damn you're about to see a show for
parents and children about tricking
people now if you're wondering who
tricky tricky people that's a nice way
to save child rapists children drinking
drinking drinking drinking people
everywhere you look bro you're trying to
[ __ ] and also what's wrong with you like
why like this dinosaur character is just
so strange he's like I looking
everywhere
there's rapist everywhere it's like at a
certain point if you see them that
frequently you're looking too hard maybe
you're looking you need to look inward
like this dinosaurs is a real true pedo
hair I mean really and it kind of my
name is Reginald charming
put this show on here today didn't I
just miss your mom by the way this is
like the the main villain with the same
Reginald charming yes last night
charming it's like these guys are
[ __ ] the guys who made this all right
I swear to God you have to touch kids to
dream the [ __ ] up like you have to have
at least have a couple of children in
your slavery dungeon the dream of this
yellow jazz talking dinosaur anti-child
rape superhero and the name of villain
mr. charming I'm mr. charming what the
[ __ ] do they sound like Chris Rock oh no
not the old puppies in the car routine
he's [ __ ] Reginald up - he's like
citizen justice I feel like I don't know
what they're advocating but this guy
hasn't raped any kids and you're letting
your strong-arming him against a wall
man also it's like such a Chris Rock
impersonation it's stripping me out it's
a great [ __ ] imagine being in middle
school and trying to extrapolate meaning
from this this is just so insane is he
explicitly a dinosaur
I don't know else he could be yeah it's
[ __ ] weird maybe he's you did you see
since city where they chop off the pedos
balls and he turns yellow maybe well
this is evolution he's a yellow man yeah
he's a castrated pedophile oh I'm an
upstanding citizen
[Music]
so dude this [ __ ] so [ __ ] so he tricks
all these little girls into doing a
photoshoot for him and he's in there
taking photos and look at his creepy
little friend like cheering him on and
then at the end which I'll show you the
dinosaur breaks into his office to get
the photos it's amazing it was all a
sting operation the arrests of the
dinosaurs well you'll see there's a
twist between the lines which I'd like
you guys to watch mutters - there's a
lot to unpack here and I'm really not
sure what's the meaning I think the
meaning is the lizards the pet Oh
everyone's the pet Oh trust nobody at
all Wow this whole pedo hysteria is so
strange like I don't know that there was
this crazy pedo hysteria when I was this
age but these days it's like don't don't
run don't play outside by yourself or
there's a hundred percent chance that
someone's gonna rape you immediately
it's like how many immediately you're in
how many rapists pedos are out there
lurking I don't know I never got show
one of these when you were growing up
though no because I'm not this one but I
explicitly remember the pedo video when
I was like in elementary school but we
have the Dan cam up we do oh great how's
it look well I'm not on it right now
Oh have you guys seen the Dan cam we
haven't used it yet the Dan cam you're
talking but it's it's hard to explain
but if I'm just sitting here like an
idiot like this and you're talking hit
the Dan cam but nobody's in the Dan cam
right now oh you're not gonna Dan cam
yeah we got Ian screening calls
all right north play I'm gonna cut to
Dan cam it's just an empty room I never
I was on the Dan Cameron it was on a Dan
cam
I was never shown any anything like this
you know all you get is like a don't get
in a car with strangers I mean what more
do you need to know don't take if some
guys offering you candy you know don't
let him put a finger in your ass unless
it's like a full tootsie roll
definitely not for like a little Tudor
oh that's not worth the finger than ass
if it was like a full-on like king-size
Tootsie Roll you could basically put
four fingers up my ass even today
frankly speaking good to know is it
great why you got a Tootsie Roll
a little later tonight you have a
dinosaur costume you want to roleplay
[Music]
oh by the way his voice changes from he
goes from he goes from what's his name
Chris Chris Rock he goes from Chris Rock
to Bruce Willis real quick hey man did
he change race his voice changed race I
want Carmen's pictures that CD looks
like a nipple am i right [ __ ] got him
that record on the wall it's a [ __ ]
nipple got him what are you talking to
oh my god
I don't know what Carmen told you but
there are no pictures give me the
combination charming
figure it out you big stupid lizard you
think you're so smart
well you can't watch them all the time
nobody can
[Music]
or finish so he takes off with the photo
so the question is the dinosaur walked
out with the photos those that is not
you that is not admissible evidence so
the question I have is were seek along
with those photos you know what I'm
saying you can't use those in court you
just barge in and stolen that it was
safe so what exactly is he doing with
those photos yeah I mean he didn't show
up at the cops he's just kind of this
vigilante who kicked in the door stole
the child porn he's going straight home
what's that yeah what the bug just like
you know share the [ __ ] wealth man I
[Laughter]
love how dramatic that God that like
take Kiki and get out of here yeah man
he's gonna go beat off to those photos
I've never been sure of anything more in
my life so that's a weird one that that
really I don't know that threw me for a
loop that video that was wild dude
amazing man they used to put kids in a
you know auditorium the whole class 500
people or whatever I don't know and
watch this I mean what I wish I had been
shown that one the one I was shown was
super awkward and just serious you know
what I mean right I think that's
probably a better approach was I'm not
sure I could extrapolate any meaning
that avoid yellow dinosaurs anyway
that's the goof of the day I hope you
guys had fun with that give it up
wasn't that a good time everybody well
we are we have up we have fun out here
they should podcast experience don't we
we have a lot of fun here let's get on
to the main stories Logan Paul Wow
who's ever talked about him MRIs that
well there was this one tweet I honestly
couldn't let go
I had to show to you guys because it
really was so insane that even even now
I read it and I was just like whoa right
he erased it
after shortly after tweeting it cuz
everyone was just like wow this isn't
saying so this is only from a couple
days ago he says and I quote board the
plane flight attendant gives me the old
I ball up and down hi Sox short shorts
saggy blond hair shaggy
saggy tits picture-perfect [ __ ] boy give
him my ticket first class stunned he
goes oh wow
and points me to my seat don't judge a
book by it's cover Wow Todd what a hero
there's there's a lot to actually unpack
here I feel like well first of all this
never happened it's just let's just
establish this right off the bat
sleepily
the only thing it's missing is everybody
in the airplane standing up and
applauded even a big applause yeah
Albert Einstein gave them yeah that and
the only thing that's missing is that
flight attendant Albert Einstein this
never [ __ ] happened dude at this
point you're like 24 there's no excuse
for running this [ __ ]
this is like what a twelve-year-old
fantasizes about then second of all he
acknowledges that he dresses like a
[ __ ] clown high socks short shorts
shaggy blond hair picture-perfect [ __ ]
boy picture if you're a [ __ ] if you're
gonna sit there and acknowledge that you
look like an idiot and that you're a
[ __ ] boy let's just change your outfit
he's basically you know what he's saying
is I'm wearing all maverick [ __ ] to sell
it to these kids but I would never want
to wear this because I look like a [ __ ]
boy but I do it like there's something
in there you know there's a weird
modicum of also awareness bigger than
their for sure like well who is this
flight attendant that's never seen a
rich
person who's apparently works
first-class their flight attendant oh
wow oh my god your first class just
imagine this person I'm so sorry
oh my god oh wow
I'm so sorry I judge you and then of
course the subtle bragging about being
rich and flying first-class but what
exactly are you asking not to judge
there's no nothing about your character
he's saying don't don't make a judgement
if someone's rich or poor be careful who
you rude to because they might be rich
the [ __ ] what's the moral of this story
Logan he's trying to bring awareness to
the rampant persecution of fuckboys in
this country that honestly is probably
the biggest social issue he's not
dealing he's not denying that he's a
fuck-boy he's like I'm a rich [ __ ] boy
and therefore you judged a book by its
cover
it's like dude basically he's saying
because he's wealthy he's superior I
mean that's really what's so nin here
and to that I say you are [ __ ] a
really a this is really one of the worst
tweets I've ever read and he always says
I'm a kid and he always says thirty year
old man and all that shake he would call
me a 33 year old man year that excuse is
not I mean this is really probably the
dumbest thing I've ever read by a public
personality how long did he keep this up
before he well that's 30,000 like so I
mean probably half a day or more was he
getting a bunch of [ __ ] for it
like what yeah I'm sure how did he
become self-aware suddenly that that is
[ __ ] awful yeah he was probably
getting [ __ ] for it and he was he's
probably trying to play it like close to
the hip these days you know mmm he's
like ooh I guess he's like I don't
understand why people don't like this
but I'm gonna remove it because I'm
trying to keep it
you know coach but i have to say i when
i read this i said stunned i said oh wow
and then you stood up and started
applauding right and then i did judge
this book by its cover
i was like we know they were right about
you dude they weren't talking about the
price the fact that you were first class
they were talking about that you're such
a douchebag
they saw this they saw him they knew it
was logan paul and they're like oh wow
this guy's a [ __ ] idiot and then
Logan's like excuse me I'm first class
and they're like yeah you're still your
that's exactly what I expected you're
[ __ ] idiot it's just a Marvel I must
want to frame this you know we should
what what is a picture-perfect [ __ ] boy
by the way oh when you when you have
done that self image like somewhat aware
but it's only got a negative
connotations hold on you don't know what
a picture-perfect [ __ ] was its high
socks short shorts shaggy blond hair
right right basically describing him
laid out he's a pimper picture perfect
[ __ ] boy I love it I want to frame this
it's the dumbest thing I've ever read I
mean genuinely I've always I've reserved
judgment for him and I'm like he's smart
like he's old he's young he's reckless
he's crazy but he's smart no no the
verdicts out this book has been read the
covers flipped this books read we're not
judging it by the cover Logan we've read
the [ __ ] book it's a bad book it's a
shitty book dude it's it's frankly this
book and I think you'll agree it's in
the bargain bin you can buy this book
for like $2 on sale right Kmart
yeah you couldn't even get it into
Walmart it's just Kmart this is in the
but this this book is frankly on sale at
Salvation Army right now for 50 cents
yeah we've read the book well anyway I
want to talk about the press conference
he added with chaos I and again I don't
want to talk about everything Paulo Paul
does but this stuff is so good and I got
to say well let's take a break we'll
talk about it when we get back we've got
the press conference to talk about
we've got BBC how to interview scheduled
for him today
to promote his fight with ksi that they
canceled they said it wasn't a good
interview that cancelled I love that
that and so so so much more
and of course Know Your Meme don't go
anywhere guys we will be right back
thank you to ring for sponsoring this
episode of the podcast let me tell you
about Ring this product it's one of
these genius products that is so perfect
time and place it changed my life let me
show you this
it's this little doorbell that goes over
your existing doorbell or if you don't
even have a doorbell you can put it and
it's got a battery that lasts a long
time it's got a microphone so you can
talk to who's out there it's got a
camera with a motion detector so if
someone's creeping in front of your door
or it's just the mailman or pizza's here
they ring they walk it opens a feed on
your phone you can also check it any
time regardless of motion and talk to
them leave the package knock on the door
whatever this thing is changing the
frickin game here you see in the bottom
right that's what it looks like you can
talk you can see them it's so freakin
powerful and amazing you know these guys
were on Shark Tank and you know what
Mark Cuban and everybody there said to
him and for those reasons amount you
know what I'm out Shark Tank because
ring went on I think it's the most
successful company that they all passed
on there it's like a billion dollar
company now and you know what and I was
reasons amount and I say to them maybe
I'm relying on the switchboard a little
too much but I'll tell you what I am
relying on ring okay they're making
neighborhoods safer they're helping
connect your home anywhere in the world
if you're on vacation you still see
what's going on at your front door you
get the motion you get it all because
it's on the internet telling you this
thing's incredible
it's got HD video and two-way audio
features changing the game I got to tell
you I have creepy people that should
come to our house that happens I can and
it saves it to the cloud so if some
creeps come into my front door that I
don't want there it saves to the cloud
I got you sucker I know if I want to
talk to her that it's my mom
I'm not huh no I'm kidding but you could
use it that way that's rude as a
listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit available right now
with a video doorbell and motion
activated floodlight camp the starter
kit has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home go to ring.com slash h3 that's a
ring dot-com / h3 whoa hello
didn't see you there I was just changing
my life with this quip electric
toothbrush you hear that
that's the pulsating of vibrating
goodness that is smack dab allotted
inside this incredible toothbrush that
Oprah has literally put on our list let
me tell you about this thing if you're
listening to the show and you have not
yet got equip then I'm not telling you
enough it's the mmm I'm obsessed with
oral hygiene okay giant bulky electric
toothbrushes are out of the question
those things cost $20 it's about the
size of a car battery not bringing that
thing with me anywhere this gives you
the same pulsing action in this little
vibrating - on top of that it tells you
when to switch sides because let's be
honest you're not brushing enough we all
know we're a bunch of sloppy nasty mouth
[ __ ] that don't brush our teeth enough
and that's why your breath stinks and
nobody wants to [ __ ] kiss you or beak
within a foot of you this is gonna
change everything for you tells you when
to switch sides it tells you when you're
done brushing I think it's like three
minutes and you know you're getting a
perfect brush every frickin time with
quip it's affordable - starts at $25 if
you go to get quick comm / h3 right now
you'll get your first refill pack for
free with a quip electric toothbrush my
friends that's your first refill pack
free we're talking about the head here
because this battery this little tube
lasts a long time this head you flip it
out every three months and you are good
to go
so you get your first refill pack free
at get quip comm /h 3 that's GE t qu IP
comm /h 3 my friends its dentist
recommended Oprah loves it what more do
you need to know other than that and let
me tell you I frickin love this
toothbrush try write full lip in now
you've all heard me talking about me
undies and if you haven't made the move
to get these undies you're slacking
underwear more like funderwear and yes
you can quote me on that me undies sushi
Oh cereal and milk forget about it
alright but the look is kind of the
least of it it's about the comfort it's
about material that is softer than
cotton more breathable and can cradle
your junk like nothing on the market now
you guys have seen me do the atomic
wedgie test okay now I defy you to find
any other brand that you can comfortably
pull above your tits that's the me
undies guarantee or your money back no
that's my guarantee
listen it's so soft it's so breathable
it's in my mouth from my balls it's
insane
okay it's sustainably sourced it's made
from beechwood do the math on that I
don't know how it's possible to turn a
tree into this but they're got
scientists on the job right now trust me
when you put on a pair you're gonna get
it all right now they've got another
thing check this out
I'm just fully nude at this point if you
like how me on these fields on your just
underwear imagine how it feels your
whole body you could see my junk it's
like a full-on zoom on my junk it feels
great that's the me undies pledge okay
forget about it
here's the best part about my undies
it's risk-free you're like oh it's just
underwear try it out and if you don't
absolutely love it no questions asked
they're gonna give you a refund
it's risk-free best underwear ever so if
you're already part of the Mandy's
family friends about it through the
referral program and you'll get a
discount and store credit when when
still not sure well me Andy's has a deal
for my listeners first-time purchasers
will get 15% off their first pair of me
undies and free shipping that's 15% off
plus free shipping and a guarantee that
you and your me undies will be very very
happy together
so get your butt on over to me undies
and treat yourself to get 50% off your
first pair free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guaranteed to go to Mandy's
Cobb / h3 that's me Andy's calm / h3 and
give yourself an atomic wedgie well
below you above your tits and I and it's
night it's gonna feel good frankly
you're gonna want to walk around like
that and that's Mandy's personal
guarantee to you
alrighty we are back thanks for sticking
around so he's on first class he's going
somewhere clearly where is he going
I think I know where he's going follow
the lead I've got it all tracked out the
press conference but si si si si Jesus
que si sound like an old man
who's the CSI guy exactly so que si
Logan Paul you guys don't know about
this boxing match I'm not gonna lie
oh I'm gonna watch the highlights I'm
not gonna sit here in front like what
like I'm not even interested going and
I'm gonna watch the highlights I'm
watching it I actually I think this is
gonna I think case I will win but I'm
standing by that I think it's gonna be a
shitty boring match ever since I heard
so they're doing two one in the UK and
one back here in LA yes and they always
arrange for it to do - I feel like it's
it's all bogus like one is gonna win one
and the other is gonna win the other I
don't think I don't what you're you're
saying that someone's gonna throw it
yeah
I'm going full conspiracy man I don't
think it's legit I don't think either of
them have neither they both have such
huge egos I don't think either of them
have it in them to get their ass beat
and throw I don't see it but if there's
like a slaughter and the first one I
mean I have no reason to believe it's
weird dad well anyway whatever let's
watch this [ __ ] video okay good sit
here and analyze this all it's just a
bunch of [ __ ] youtubers box and like
it's [ __ ] like the concept is just so
stupid
they're gonna make so much money dude
[Applause]
anyway watching this video I actually
start to feel bad for Logan Paul in a
way he's just he gets creamed he's the
heel
he just got a wrestling heel she's so
embarrassing like he just gets creamed
by chaos I then Logan's Logan's dad of
all people come out and try to defend
him it's like dude
his dad is crunchy as [ __ ] and it's just
like a total [ __ ] show it's just so
embarrassing you know what Logan's
thinking he's like dude this is my this
may well be my last chance to make money
so I'm gonna endure this I wonder how
much they both make him from this I want
to crush some numbers right now let's
crunch numbers
I think there's 20,000 seats I don't
think they're gonna sell it I think
maybe they'll sell let's be generous and
say they sell 10,000 seats okay 10,000
let's say it's a hundred on average per
ticket and they get less let's just do
revenue right okay they're charging a
hundred [ __ ] dollars do it I could do
this thing yeah Jesus so that's a
million but then they're doing
pay-per-view and all this [ __ ]
they'll have a lot of live streamers I
don't know how many how many
pay-per-view tickets can they sell of
this I don't know not that much 10,000 I
mean I don't know right for the online
yeah he's an online thing yeah it's an
online paper merging for that - Wow
they'll sell more than 10,000 let's say
it's 25 for the stream so what do you
think they sell I mean okay let's say 50
that seems generous but maybe I'm wrong
maybe it's 100 I don't know 50,000
that's another I mean you're looking at
two million but then the the venue gets
half you're down to a million split
between the two
I feel like this calculation can't be
right I feel like they got to be making
more money from this you know it's $14
for an online ticket it looks like dude
they're [ __ ] not making that much
money from this he's humiliating himself
for like a hundred I mean maybe I'm out
of touch a little bit most people are
like dude I would eat my own [ __ ] for a
hundred thousand dollars and you're
right but like McGregor like Mayweather
got paid three hundred million [ __ ]
dollars or something how much did he get
for that fight I don't know look it up
I'm sure it's somewhere around there
like so you know in comparison which is
what they're trying to do regardless
watch this I am very curious how much
money they're they're they're you know
about to make from it if you can look
that up let me know down yeah I just
pulled it up 300 million from Mayweather
and Conor McGregor hundred around 100
million how the [ __ ] is there that much
money in a single fight the fighters
alone got 400 million dollars what am I
missing
well well okay well what I'm missing is
that that was like the fight of the
century
and probably like a million plus people
bought the pay-per-view right yeah I
mean it's two legends you know ksi and
look and Paul I mean they're legends bit
of a of a different cost I'm really cure
don't see that many people buying the
pay-per-view because everyone's just
gonna want to watch the highlights just
don't h3h3 live reaction stream uh-huh
bootleg their bootleg they're still like
the pay-per-view
that might be illegal come at me [ __ ]
No
this stick again yeah you already did
this dad
[Applause]
you know what let me just skip to the
good parts which is basically he shits
on and he shits on them I really like
when his dad gets involved that's your
old man okay here's when the dad gets
along this is disgusting delusional
[Applause]
disgusting
his dad is there on stage why is your
dad there Doug you're trying to look
badass don't bring your [ __ ] dad who
makes up with little girls yeah I was
about to say this is the same dad that I
got sick he's like you know it would be
badass at this press conference
my dad don't judge a book by it's cover
you [ __ ] peasant ass stewardess you
know what's funny about Logan Paul he
probably buys his dad a coach ticket
because they come here I said like I
authorized you know Logan Falls that
kind of dude who would buy himself a
first-class ticket and his dad's in
coach dad you're not you're not a
first-class [ __ ] boy like me
all right listen dad the entourage is
pretty big I'm gonna have to stick you
in coach all the way back next to the
bathroom don't judge a book by it's
cover dude don't you have a job how is
this his what how is his dad turned into
his hype man don't you have a job he's
like my son is really famous I'm gonna
ride his coattails and kiss his many
little 16 year-olds as possible his dad
is like all in like he's Logan Paul's
dad now
like he walks around people like oh
you're that guy that makes up little
girls on Jake Paul's Channel yeah
anyway you beat me in the fight you said
you beat me in the fight with one hand
right
you wouldn't do [ __ ] you're an old man I
mean that's just factual he's like
you're an old man it's not really even
on an insult she's like you we're not an
equal fighting match you're an old man
so yeah that is true frankly but I'm
sure I'm sure you wouldn't mind loss of
one wonderful little girl she liked
kissing this is so good
he's [ __ ] dad is getting roasted team
Paul look he wants to get in there oh
yeah oh by the way look at Jake Paul on
the top left looking like Elton John bro
what the [ __ ] the 80s called
you see him no you see him right here
look at this
look he looks like he looks like 90 at
the Roxbury zas looking [ __ ] hold on
let's take it full screen do you not see
this am I crazy
no you're not crazy Jake Paul's looking
like he's out for the night of the
Roxbury dude is it is it viewable in the
stream no we can't see it it's like
cuddle oh no this is important yeah what
there is you can't see full screen where
you mean it was just cropped it just the
very cuz he's right on the edge it was
just cut off ever so slightly we see it
now okay why does it look like Jake Paul
is about to drop the corniest 80 single
right now blue damn
the whole team is just that's a whole
bunch of winners what - Jake Paul dude I
can't go over this look he's not even
there he's like out in outer space he's
like zoned the [ __ ] out
he's like watching cartoons in his head
right now blue tinted glasses night at
the Roxbury ass lookin [ __ ] I think
maybe he's just like reflecting on how
embarrassed he is of his dad no his
dad's as a role model mmm Tim Paul
dumbass children [ __ ] God
get him dad my dad got you good yeah
what the [ __ ] my dad just burned you hey
Dad you want to take care of hey Dad you
want to get the mic and take care of
this hey dad this guy ksi is talking
[ __ ] you want to take care of this what
does he do what does his dad do I wonder
like what's his job now probably nothing
right
no but he's done clearly he's clearly I
wonder what's his job within the
organization you know what I mean
God Jake Paul is such a phony
he looks like someone who's trying to be
someone else yeah whatever he's a
commercial roofer and license real oh he
is I just looked it up according to
priceless he's he is a realtor they
honestly frankly all these Paul's should
be Realtors like I was talking last
episode about like why YouTube makes
people famous you have no right to be
these Paul brothers have a let they have
a legacy and being Realtors they should
have a Realtor family business where
they all just selling houses in Ohio
should be on bus stops I can see Logan
appalled with a receding hairline
he's at a house you know a couple hours
for the client shows up he's cleaning
making sure it's nice yeah there's all
three of their faces on a bus stop and
lo marquee yeah let's do some questions
don't throw anything calm down I'll be
honest
[ __ ] you loca [ __ ] you later
[ __ ] you loco he looks like he's about
to Christina looks heartbroken right now
he looks like a broken man answer your
questions I address everything on 25th
oh you just mike troubles
yeah he bails yeah exactly
this is buttered I think he I think dude
he's not in a good place Logan I think
he's yeah anyway we talking about he's
he's got to be so happy
nah but his dad's got his [ __ ] back
yeah his dad's got his back through
thick and thin for sure and then on top
of it BBC was had an interview with
Logan to promote the fight and they
tweeted this out today we were going to
hear from Logan Paul and ksi on their
boxing match tonight after listening
back to the interview we don't feel it's
right we understand some of your strong
views on Logan but ultimately we don't
if we don't think the interview is good
enough we don't air it they thought the
interview they're like it's not about
that you guys don't like Logan it's
about that the interview sucked that
this guy had nothing interesting to say
and so we didn't air it like this is the
best burn ever the like we acknowledge
that we all hate him and that's not why
we aired it we aired it because it
sucked dick
[ __ ] pretty brutal and he would be a
killer realtor though you could probably
yeah he would be killer realtor I buy a
trailer park for me alright well guys
it's about that time for an episode of I
got its knees Oh God alright an episode
uh not an episode of know your me that's
right everybody welcome to another
episode of know your meme today's
episode is about your favorite virgin
Skippy the virgin we have got callers
lined up to play so with that being said
let's take a call from our very first
player we have got which was the one you
liked in it was I don't see her anymore
it was Rachel did Rachel bounce Rachel
damn and help me quick all right I'm
just gonna take one we bet he's got he
said he put it in priority order okay
let's do this Nick you are on the air
are you ready to play Know Your Meme all
right I dropped that that was not a good
quality call and frankly this is no time
for playing around okay
I'm building that
next up we've got Sarah
Sara it's an eyebrow you are on the air
are you ready to play Know Your Meme I
am most ready o most ready okay I like
the sound of that
Sara how are you I am very good you're
very calm I like that about you you got
your [ __ ] together you got your game
face on where you from I am from
Wisconsin oh no people yeah it's cheese
right that's the whole thing do you like
you know cheese I love cheese uh
excellent eat very good very good
round of applause she likes cheese very
good
she likes cheese Sarah loves cheese okay
right like I know you already
so are you playing the answers because I
don't have them on my computer I have
the answers or cued up ready to go okay
first question who is Skippy's celebrity
crush is it a Emma Watson be Oprah
Winfrey or see going old-school Gwyneth
Paltrow A or C I would say he if he
seems like a classy man yeah it's a good
guess she's a business lady
she's industrious she's got a lot going
on Dan is it C
my celebrity crush number one I think
that Oprah is one of the most amazing
people on the planet and like meet time
and spend time with any celebrity it
would be Oprah I want to be around Oprah
Wow he wants to be around Oprah Wow I
have to say that one was a little
unexpected Skippy wants to bang Oprah
that surprises me frankly would it be my
first choice either but very good guess
but don't worry you have four more
questions still to sell let's move it on
to question two how are you feeling
are you ready are you prepared I mean
yeah I'm pretty prepared I think you're
wait you're almost too calm but that's
okay okay how many girls has Skippy
kissed zero a beef 9 mm or C 49 guitar
I'm gonna go with thee Wow no hesitation
what what what makes you think that I'm
49
I know he's gotten to a second 1/2 base
really couple of times geez she's and
she watches Skippy I love it yeah okay
guys I feel like that's a really easy
thing for me to remember it's 49
[Applause]
I gotta say that shocked me when I heard
he had kissed 14 others I was like damn
Skippy was [ __ ] like crazy like if he
wasn't a warming he would be like
probably have STDs it's dill Mary mm-hmm
would you kiss Skippy uh I would give
that a soft maybe you give him a peck
yeah you give him a soft what does that
mean like a soft kiss uh it would be
like I feel sorry for you a little bit
we can't make it to the next stage no
sorry he's your consolation prize
do you are you attracted to men who
picked belly button lint out of their
stomach and keep it in a jar by their
bed no I would have to say probably not
well I find that a little bit judgmental
Sarah but but you are your own person
and I don't judge you you've got one
point on the board okay so actually here
we go question number three what's the
furthest bass Skippy has gotten to a
[Music]
second and a half in other words he's
fingered girls when he's got his dick
touched it
third base oral or first base which is
you know just a peck you seem to know a
lot about okay describing the bases yeah
the bases you know I think it's I think
it's a you sound confident
no hesitation
nope veera hesitation looking around the
Skippy knowledge man wow you're good
well I like to I like when the music
gets tense I feel like you're not giving
me a chimp like you know you gotta let
the tension build you're too confident
you're too quick oh okay I'll wait for
the next one no but you could be
yourself but also don't be yourself to
make the show better Dan the answer is
there is the furthest they're gone let's
just put this way I was going between
second and third but I ended up getting
tagged out by the shortstop
I've been clutched and had such but
haven't quite gotten the fifth we're
mouths on body part yeah I have to say
your knowledge of Skippy you got a girl
you've got two points on the board I may
give it up man is the second you must
say that yeah you knew right away I may
or may not have brushed up on my Skippy
knowledge you're an advanced player I
definitely tip my beanie to you now he
said he's got a second and a half base
if you had to imagine what do you think
that would necessarily mean uh like his
dick got a little bit wet but not crazy
way a little wet like a little kiss like
a little kiss interesting a little bit
kiss here can I do I can I do
there's got to be a sound effect for
that
[Applause]
yeah I'm Megan you're right probably got
it a little bit wet and to that I said
once again say Skippy you're really
surprising me if it wasn't for this
Mormon thing he would just be [ __ ]
like crazy he's crushing it honestly I
know I love the image of him being
stopped between bases like he got he got
tagged out he was in he's happening
probably came downstairs yeah that might
be actually accurate what happened I'm
gonna give you a laugh all right tension
this one's for all the tamales oh man
what's the most trouble skips trouble
Skippy has ever gotten with his bishop
we've taught heard him talk about his
bishop this is the man at his church who
passes judgment on him he's basically
the gatekeeper to the afterlife great
right so a he got in trouble for all the
Handy's he's been getting as we as we've
called it rounding the third base but
being struck out for masturbating too
much or see getting drunk which is
strictly against the Mormon faith mm-hmm
Sarah what is your think deeply enter
the mind of the Mormon enter the mind of
the virgin I would say it's probably
masturbating too much masturbating too
much a very violent very very good guess
I would guess the he masturbates at
least seven times a day at least
dan is it a stir among gone to second
base with multiple girls I thought if
we're using the baseball analogy I got
sidelined by my bishop and was told not
to take the communion for a while so in
the Mormon Church they call it being
dissed fellowship disfellowshipped a
sadly you had a great great guess you
had a great guess he probably does
masturbate a lot
and to that I'll give you all the credit
that I can but it was actually from all
the Handy's he was getting and he got
disfellowshipped which is a word that
makes me giggle I love it but this is
okay this last question everything rides
on this question to to to the Sarat we
are on the board to to to the tense
music is on now Sarah what kind of phone
are using currently I am using a Google
pixel that has a very cracked screen
oh so this is this is this big let me
tell you what's on the line here okay
this is a brand-new s 9 Plus this is the
best phone on the market there's no
question about it and let me tell you
what else what else it has my DNA on it
oh don't clone okay here we go the
question to decide it all what what kind
of collection did Skippy give us to
auction for charity
was it a toenail clippings B eyelashes
or C bellybutton lint
it was definitely see and smelled like
your grandmother's closet sir
and one of the cooler things dad I was I
was drawing it up I didn't say go I
played it early dan you're the drummel
you play it one bit of the symbol when
you hear this describe it I did don't
get technical you know what I mean
that doesn't mean play I'm just telling
you when I hit that all right yeah what
is the answer one of the coolest things
that ever happened in my entire life was
when my belly button lint collection of
almost 20 years was given to h3h3
what's the greatest greatest fall on the
market how are you feeling right now I
am so excited oh I'm happy to do that
would you ever think that you want to
think I'd like to thank my baby girl for
keeping during this entire process
oh god bless you god bless her what a
sweet angel Oh Dan told me kill the
music I guess that wasn't that really
that great Sara you're the greatest you
know what a new phone stay on the line
we're gonna hook you out I don't know
thank you for calling in and God look
good yeah I think you appreciate you all
right Papa bless Papa bless do I need to
mute her something down
yeah just put her uh don't don't take
this don't take this personally Sara but
I get it you muted shut up Dan you got
it I'm Joe I'm doing drama out here I
know I'm milky I'm doing drama you can't
just be you can't willy nilly just plays
sound bites whenever you want
unbelievable on you hear this that's
drama I didn't hit the Signet the simple
where the money went for hurricane
relief I hear the simple I play
I'm not kidding dude anyway that was fun
that was a good time
Sarah was a great collar there was a
great I love this I love this segment
it's so much fun got my DNA on it send
an e in to get her info I was great I
know so much fun who should we do next I
wonder so we actually this show is let's
just do the Roseanne I mean I've got a
lot of great stuff here but I kind of
want to go over it with with ela one
thing in particular I really want to
talk about is that we tell previously
that meaning either trying to have kids
so I want to do a semen analysis and I
was it was the room was unbelievable
where you go in there and squirt in a
cup I was taking pictures and videos of
this room because it's like you can't
imagine what's going on in there but I
want to wait till eel is sitting across
from me so she can you you need to see
her reaction to this so there's a lot of
stuff I want to talk about but I want to
close up the show with Roseanne you guys
have heard about Roseanne the situation
of her calling I don't remember this
lady she said she looked like a monkey
sure show got cancelled so she's finally
issued an explanation she's finally
issued a statement an apology of sorts
that I think clears everything up and I
think you guys will all agree so in her
own words is it loud enough out there
Dan I don't want to hear ya know what
it's fine because only she's miked
everybody else is just getting ambience
so once she starts talking on sound fine
I get frustrated with Dan we have sound
issues and I yell at Dan you guys have
any sound issues with the unbalanced or
itchy at weird [ __ ] email Dan and give
him give him he'll
sounds good we don't have chat anymore
so we don't even know for [ __ ] up
anymore
by the way this figure ain't in another
video she explains that this is a statue
of her body
Oh maybe Skippy's into that maybe maybe
DeRozan would be that kind of surprised
me that Skippy wants to [ __ ] Oprah
there's mine out too figurine with your
mouse I just took it fullscreen right
here yeah there she is
does it surprise you that Skippy wants
to [ __ ] Oprah I mean that's kind of cool
he's like damn it you don't want to
[ __ ] you know who owned around third
base on Oprah I wonder what was very
surprised when he said that what base is
ass play because that that's the dugout
the metaphor kinda breaks down cuz it's
like ass play is almost more advanced
than a home run in a way and in most
circles anyway no way yeah someone if
Skippy's ever fingered an [ __ ] why do
I hear talking in the background oh is
that Ian that must be in through your
mic alright look at Sarah's info okay
alright well anyway as a digression in
her own words
here's Roseanne explaining hello hello
hello hello okay
oh and you said I'm in three outfits
there's the problem like imagine are you
filming
yes imagine a presidential address like
you're busted with the killing a hooker
like whatever what just no hear me out
and they say tonight the president's
gonna give his address and they and then
the camera fades out and it's [ __ ]
the president on his desk in the Oval
Office and he's like I did not have sex
with that hooker right imagine in his
statement and save his job
there were jump cuts multiple outfits
difference I'm trying to talk about
anyone I'm trying to talk about Valerie
Jarrett rub the ear on yeah you've told
me this 300
do you know that if that's what my tweet
was about I know you've explained this
literally I thought the bench was wide I
thought the [ __ ] was wide so that
clears it up so there's flex so there's
a lot of interesting things here about
this view first of all this is on her
this is on her official YouTube channel
this was uploaded by her her directly
onto the road anyway it's this is
probably my favorite clip to come out of
this whole possibly a year 2018 this
might be the strongest clip of the whole
year Rosanna what do you have to say in
your defense his job
there were jump cuts yeah you've told me
this 300 times do you know what is wrong
with her she's like I don't think she's
on drugs but like my god she's like
breaking down I was like Christ
she doesn't look good this was posted
this this previous week right this is
very recent you think it was recorded
recently or was this right after the
incident this is recent maybe this is
this is after some thoughtful after some
but like the question is well here after
some after I love this this is so good
after some careful consideration and
some thoughtful reflection Rosanna has
decided to issue a statement on her
controversial tweet that's what my tweet
was about I know you've explained this
literally no I've got an interesting
question for you do you think this in a
way does this help her no okay why
almost I'm more inclined to believe her
because she's like she's very passionate
she's very passionate about it I'm I'm
somewhat inclined to believe that that
it wasn't necessarily coming from a
place of racism
stuff of that statement that's a strong
statement however I'm also inclined to
believe that she's a [ __ ] psycho what
makes you think that what makes you say
well Dan I don't know just something
something something about well if she
goes about it all right anyway guys um
you know I just thought that there's
really a lot of value here I thought
this was a great clip and I thought well
and let me let me draft this in another
way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and for those reasons amount I don't
I've been waiting to do that for a long
time
I got this sound boy here's I have
another one the angels in heaven this
one's better
[Music]
I think the curb wants better I love
this sound board I feel like I feel like
a DJ for the first time I live but here
actually this is funny this is like
right when they start rolling that was
like her off-the-cuff thing have you
ever seen someone famous so unhinged in
your life it was so fascinating about it
it's crazy to see anybody that unhinged
but it does kind of give you an insight
to how how [ __ ] up she is kind of in a
way it's like whoa probably shouldn't
have been working on that show to begin
with you know if that's where you're at
mentally you know I'm saying but so then
take two
she gets her [ __ ] together by the way
whether they put that on our official
channel man I just love that so much
so this is her actual you know real
statement on that bar and I'd like to
welcome you to my own studio - my fellow
and sister Americans without the filter
of the biased media this is my statement
from the very beginning and it will
continue to be ever when ABC called and
asked me to explain my egregious and
unforgivable tweet I told them I thought
Valerie Jarrett was white and I'm
willing to go on the view Jimmy Kimmel
or whatever other show you want me to go
on
my audience now in the judge what
happened was about 40 minutes after that
my show was cancelled before even one
advertiser pulled out and I was labeled
a racist why you ask
well the answer is simple it's because
I'm and that is not allowed in Hollywood
pretty shitty well okay so ma'am well
first of all it wasn't the whole premise
of the show that she was like a trump
voter and like so clearly obviously not
that I think in a way they gave you the
show because you were a trump supporter
because they thought it was interesting
dynamic right so that doesn't make sense
although I do actually do believe that
she thought she was white because I've
seen a picture and the lady doesn't she
my first guess wouldn't be black and I
mean if you can elicit this response
that's but at any rate she's I don't
know if let's say let's say if she did
think she was white then is the tweet
like how bad is the tweet still you know
what I mean yeah I mean obviously it
doesn't have the whole connotation of
calling a black person a monkey that
everyone thought it did so it's not as
but like the context does help but it's
still she's unhinged she was probably on
thin ice already
he had the executives at ABC because she
just non-stop was ranting on Twitter
about all kinds of games and can you
imagine working with that I mean I'm
sure that's isolated incident yeah I
actually when I think what happened like
you said it's probably that they were
like all right like enough this is not
yeah this this is not gonna get better
but see I mean just to kind of line that
up in a way how do you here's a clip
again this is all on her personal
YouTube channel which is so fascinating
to me but um here's here's a little
soundbite they uploaded right before
they started shooting the first season
of her new
dude you're so [ __ ] tired how did you
do this for 10 years are you [ __ ] me
I lost my [ __ ] mind
I lost my marriage I had to lock my
[ __ ] kids up I marriage a dipwad and
that [ __ ] half and one bro
that [ __ ] do you think that's like the
hospital is for four different nervous
breakdowns that's how I did it
thanks for asking
it's pretty wild man she's a [ __ ]
character you know what Rosanna she's
such a character I don't know
if I don't know it's so hard to say you
know with uh sorry to say but either way
we've got this wonderful sound bite that
I think will truly live in infamy I
don't see this going anywhere off my
soundboard for a long so good um like I
said let's see what else we've got here
we've got our we've got all this stuff
we've got some great [ __ ] I'm gonna save
this though we've got the news we should
just hit the news get the news but
before we do hit the news we're gonna
bring back the news by the way but
before we do
[Music]
maybe it's just me having fun there's a
possibility that there's thousands of
people watching right now and saying
please stop [ __ ] doing I'm having a
great time though alright then give us
the news alright hit them with the
stinger alright let's do the news
everybody you got to flip your TVs other
input by the way so you can follow along
right right
alright so top story today come in to us
from CNBC here I'm sure a lot of people
heard about this Facebook and it work PC
or is it HTML no HDMI - yeah yeah yeah
hello
it's [ __ ] oh my god there you go
a-all right so yeah top story we got
Facebook loses a hundred billion dollars
plus in market cap this past week their
shares plunged on Thursday I guess it
was Wednesday after hours by 20% which
it was in response to them announcing
that they're they're gonna up their
spending on privacy concerns and
fighting fake news on the platform and
people were like [ __ ] that I want that
Russian money right and I guess it
basically is more so about they're gonna
be spending a ton of money to do this
and that kind of coupled with the fact
that I guess their user growth has
really slowed down surprise surprise
Facebook [ __ ] sucks nobody wants to
sign up anymore and so it's just kind of
created this perfect storm where yeah in
a single night hundred billion dollars
disappeared off the market single
biggest loss for a cup
a single biggest lover and just to give
some perspective number two I looked
this up as on September 22nd the year
2000 intel lost ninety billion so about
18 years that was you know the dot-com
crash that happened at the end of the
90s well sort of result what I'd like to
say is suck my dick
Facebook [ __ ] you Mark Zuckerberg [ __ ]
you Facebook I cannot wait for Facebook
to become the next myspace I've said
this all the time but I hate everything
about Facebook and I'm so [ __ ] glad
by the way I read a report they like
their earnings from them stealing
content from where everywhere else on
the internet like the earnings aren't
good and the engagement isn't good and
all I have to say is and for those
reasons I'm out [ __ ] you Facebook I am
so glad to see that website die
well maybe don't get too excited yet
because apparently they were up 20% this
year so they're basically just back to
where they were a few months ago well
let's see it let's let's wash this baby
slide yeah we'll see what happens what
else you got in the news Dan alright so
next up Papa John oh no Papa John we
talked about this a couple weeks ago or
last week and not not having a great
month I'm having a great July Papa John
the man is now suing Papa John the
company oh no he's going after I'm John
Shatner Civil War
it's the Civil War it's the Pizza wars
and no the Pizza wars are upon us when
Papa John fights Papa John you know who
wins nobody little seizures oh yeah
you're right you're right
oh I love this description Shatner has
admitted tis he said the n-word on a
conference call with a marketing firm
Shatner claimed the firm asked if he was
racist listen are you racist then he
used the n-word in scribing house KFC's
Colonel Sanders used to talk Shatner has
since also said they told the firm that
he himself wouldn't ever use that word
after having used the word right which
is kind of the confusing part of this
whole thing is he's like acknowledging
that he said it but also denying that he
said it in this wall he did I've always
when I when I saw that headline and then
I read the article I was like well again
I do think there needs to be just like I
haven't we all [ __ ] kind of lost our
minds a little bit I mean he shouldn't
have said it that's for sure if a
marketing company asks are you racist
don't drop the n-bomb does show how not
racist you are just basically what it
did but like he didn't like use the he
didn't weaponize the word he didn't use
the word he was talking about the word
right you know what I mean like the
headline like some thought the draw
drops to N bond the conference call and
you're like wool like he was just like
called someone n-word or someone not
exactly what happened but I mean you
know Papa John he's sliding that guy
spent he spent way too much time close
to a pizza oven his face is like melting
off like that mozzarella cheese is like
it's in the pores it's man that pizza is
ready to you can tree bake that pizza
that Beach has been baked too many times
so yeah so he's going after them saying
that you know he was unfairly forced out
as the head and I guess he's I thought
he was out completely I guess it was
just that he was forced out as the
chairman he still owns 29% of the
company
well he was on the board of directors
and then they bid and right and so he's
still got his his claws in it a little
bit but they're they're trying real hard
to get rid of I love is Papa John he's
the man Papa Bo needs to step up and
usurped power you got that meme I saw
this meme and I really think they all
yeah this kind of says it all you can't
trust anybody even yourself what happens
when Papa John tries to execute Papa
John's ah stop provoking really man
what's next some deep stuff all right
let's see what is next
oh this is really cool so this week a
team of Italian researchers announced
that after analyzing some data for the
last two years
they are saying with a high degree of
confidence that they have discovered a
lake of water on Mars it is under the
southern polar cap and I guess this is
very similar
the reason they knew to look for this
specific thing is there's these kind of
lakes in an archives here on earth in a
very similar fashion and so they were
using there's this european space
mission called the Mars Express orbiter
that was able to use ground-penetrating
radar and they detected what looked like
a lake but they weren't sure but again
after analyzing this for the last two
years they with a high degree of
confidence are able to say this is a Wow
20 kilometer wide lake sitting an hour
and a half under the ice cap any
estimate when we can get anything up
there to do some digging yes I mean
that's the problem it's it's that still
a ways off just because of the weight of
all the equipment you would need and you
need a drill that can go almost a mile
straight that's gonna be so thrilling
who can cut into that ice like if they
find like there's two options or there's
three options really one option is that
they find life that is identical and DNA
to ours which could mean that life
originated on Mars right and then like a
meteor impact or something sperm did
onto earth and then the second option is
that it's different completely different
the third options there's nothing there
they're all fascinating in their own
right the craziest one for me would be
like if it's completely a different
origin of life sure but if you do find
life I feel like the most likely would
be that it's the same DNA I feel like
yeah and I think you're right though
that if it were completely different
from life on earth that that robably the
coolest thing because that just says
okay so it developed completely
independently on two planets in the
solar system that means it's everywhere
also how much like hot look to see
another alien life-form that has a
completely different building blocks
would be I'm the discovery of the life I
can I cannot wait for that that's so
cool
god bless really awesome really awesome
stuff so good job good job Italy Italy
great killing it over there
next up so I don't know if everybody I'm
sure everybody's heard about this so
James Gunn got fired from the guardians
of the galaxy three because some old
tweets got dug up from about ten years
ago of him making some you know pretty
pretty distasteful what was what was the
joke or you have if you have an example
so I have one example and in the words
of the article this is from
Entertainment Weekly this was one of the
only ones they could reprint so I can
only imagine the rest were pretty bad
too this one was laughter is the best
medicine that's why I laugh at people
with AIDS who [ __ ] cares that's not
that you know seriously yeah yeah now
they did say this again this is
potentially one of the least I'm the
worst ones
yeah and find find the worst one they've
all been they've all been scrubbed yes
come on they're out they're on they I'm
sure they're out there they're out there
Ian fine I let's let's see you know
that's not bad let's see what yeah I
mean that's that's not the worst but
here's the whole Ian are you looking in
switching the the computer he's in the
hot seat right you look you can find
them I'm googling it was on it okay so
basically what this all is is you know
James Gunn
he's pretty outspoken critic of Trump
and some this right-wing group that
didn't like that he was talking all the
[ __ ] decided to kind of troll through
all of his old tweets and everything and
yeah I mean I guess James Gunn has been
on Twitter forever and so there was
thousands and thousands of these things
and James Gunn if anybody knows anything
about James Gunn he he's an edgy dude
like that everything before doing the
guardians of the galaxy movies that he's
ever done was pretty wrong so what's the
what's the headline well so the headline
is there's a campaign to get him to get
him rehired it was [ __ ] that they
fired him and
and you know the fans they they love the
Guardians movies they think he's done a
good job they don't care and they want
him back and as of yesterday three
hundred thousand signatures in a matter
of I think two or three days so Disney
ela found uh oh yeah let's here give me
more give me the most because that that
wouldn't have got him fired alright so
here's an I'll Ike when little boys
touch me in my silly place another
that's pretty cranky I mean that's the
thing none of these are even really the
sex it's it's really not funny at all
the best thing about being raped is when
you're done being raped and it's like
whew this feels great not being raped
can you imagine tweeting that yeah it's
like so embarrassing well and he's
embarrassed I mean he said like I was an
idiot
I was just trying to be edgy I'm not
this person anymore ten years think back
ten years ago how much like of a person
you can change I mean the weird thing is
like Disney hired this guy who has a
reputation and now all the sudden
they're shocked what's James gone this
whole thing of firing someone for a
tweet they made ten years ago so obscene
and I and I think Disney now is probably
like maybe we were may I don't know if
they're regretting it but I don't think
I don't think a trillion signatures will
ever make Disney eat its hat they'll
never change their minds no and that's
yeah I doubt it too even if they got
triple those things what else you have
any other tweets I actually enjoy
there's a there's a bunch here what else
he says so others at maids teracle
comments about 9/11 aids the Holocaust
described a monkey masturbating on a
young child and whose contrary that made
him extremely happy right me it's wait
it looks like those were the only ones
that they tweeted something kind of some
more examples of the type of thing but
again that's that's what Disney will not
rehire him because you know this is
Disney and they do that right but why
did they hire them in the first place
then everybody like did they not know
who he was
companies are such [ __ ] [ __ ] these
days like like the minute they sniff
controversy yeah it's like everybody
shut the [ __ ] door you know what I
mean
no saying listen listen this goes out to
every company out there that's thinking
about firing someone because they did
something offensive let me come on
she's white technically the same company
she got fired by ABC which is Disney
didn't tell it's everything
yeah it's isn't Disney owns like the
butt plug that you see and they have a
butt plug brand do that
yeah they own everything I don't know
what you said about plug but like I
don't know they own Disney owns
everything didn't they just buy out a
huge company well they're buying Fox
they're trying to and it looks like it's
happening there was a little bit of a
back-and-forth they were in a bidding
war but they're they're gonna win Disney
Disney when they own every company in
America that's when that's when fascism
will be here cuz you're not gonna be
able to make any jokes at all and then
youyou like is you weren't gonna factory
all the sudden they own like fulfillment
factories and you can't joke about the
Holocaust anymore suddenly oh six
million shut it down you know what I'm
saying yeah I do for the record think
those numbers are accurate or you know
no Holocaust but I will say that 9/11 is
highly suspicious
oh yeah and let me tell you there's
nothing I love more than monkeys jerk
that wants a weird one that he would
tweet ah I like monkeys jerking on kids
that's a [ __ ] weird image dog yep I
don't mind you know let's move on so
next up
next up uh this is an article from enemy
I thought this was interesting and I
mean it's a British entertainment
magazine there are seven Robin Hood
movies Russell Crowe Robin Hood movie
well know that already got made that's
the UH yeah Ridley Scott I believe oh is
that a good movie no okay
by the way you haven't heard of it it's
not good at all that's a shame so that's
an older one but yet they are in this
era of reboots and relaunches and
restarts and all the Riesz you said
seven
did they not get the memo that like
everyone else was making Robin Hood
movie yeah that's a good question I mean
they all have kind of their own take on
it to be fair but does anybody even give
a [ __ ] about Robin Hood
like I like Robin Hood excuse me Dan
okay I like Robin Hood you're the target
audience well guess what there cannot be
thrilled to hear I'm gonna be busy this
fall so just to quickly just rattle them
off we've got a movie called Robin Hood
origins or it was called Robin Hood
origins it's since been I don't know I
got a Robin I'm gonna stop I don't need
seven Robin okay all right fair enough
look them up yourself everybody if
you're if you're curious I sensed I
sense this yeah that's a lot of Robin
it's a lot of Robin
yeah to be fair that's a lot of Robin
Hood alright next story
this was actually like two weeks ago
this is too good we we had to had to do
it I had to do it to him oh there's a
flight in China that lost pressure and
dropped 20,000 feet because the pilots
were vaping in the cockpit how does that
happen how's what's the correlation so
they were vaping and it got so full or
hotboxing though they were hotboxing the
cockpit Wow yes yeah and it got and
basically they didn't want the vapor to
escape into the passenger cabin and give
away the fact that they were doing this
so the copilot tried to flip a switch
that would keep the air from cycling
into the rest of the cabin and hit the
wrong button which depressurized the
cabin was there why is there a button to
depressurize the cabin mid-flight anyway
that seems like a little danger that's a
good question I mean maybe there's some
preventative thing that they need to do
that occasionally for but but yeah I
guess it was right next to the other
switch and it was so so much [ __ ]
dank babe smoke in there that they hit
the wrong button and just had to kind of
barrel down all the oxygen masks dropped
and yeah so maybe nation the air over in
China were they executed when they
learned in China I mean it is China so
let's just say that nobody's heard from
her hi babe nature's
I hope wherever you are you're vaping in
heaven now what everyone's okay god
bless how is our last this is actually
the last story here a Colombian drug dog
has been moved into witness protection
for lack of a better turn after a gang
in Colombia put a hit on this dog the
dog named Sombra which means shadow in
English OH which sniffed out a record
amount of drugs in her career has been
forced to be moved to ensure her safety
she's this dog is smoked smoked had
sniffed out 5.3 tonnes of cocaine to
that dogs [ __ ] awesome yeah there
although it says here the hit is only
70,000 they're gonna I think feel like
yeah which is by the way 200 million
Colombian pesos yeah you were stalking
it cause like a million pesos for like
low for bread well yeah and just to put
in some perspective in 2012 there was a
whole incident where the gang had put
out a hits on police officers offering
$500 whoa so so by comparison this dog
is the dog plumpie are murdering people
for five police for five hundred dollars
well well the article about it says that
they found leaflets signed by the game
offering $500 I don't know if anybody
actually took them up it's like a
broke-ass gang bible you're broke
because of this dog [ __ ] busting all
their coke
so that's sad as hell that's come on
guys it's a [ __ ] dog you can kill
people you can kill helpless civilians
but spare the dog leave the dogs out of
it people come on alright so there is
this this is Sombra a little hero right
here I hope I pray for him hmm so that's
it that's it that's the news that's
that's the Horde that's everything guys
that's everything that's out there yeah
oh no there's a couple things I want to
do first before we go out first of all
where the [ __ ] did I want to bring Ian
out I don't remember
oh oh yeah I wanted to make n smell the
belly button lint feel like I missed the
train though but
it is Dan's birthday recently we wanted
to honor Dan for his birthday
dan would you come join us here for a
minute and I told him I wish I could
bring hangout to but would have enough
people here and I'm gonna make it I want
to make you sniff this it's a it's a
rite of passage that everyone in this
crew needs to abide by so Dan it is your
birthday you do mean a lot to us here at
the HP podcast thank you we want to we
really want to honor honor that that day
well what's your age 31 31 yeah big one
right well here you go dude please do
enjoy read it you can open it now yeah
open it of course good today you are a
Bar Mitzvah hold this up as we can see
it all so handsome fun
good-natured oh this whole we're going
on a journey
yes sir it's work okay kind smart and
caring yep you're a mensch and a
blessing in so many ways what more could
any family asked for so proud of you
dan would leave what did you get Mazel
Tov and lots of love and a gift card the
Hot Topic everybody how much for holy
[ __ ] 15 bucks bare minimum that's any
amount between 15 and 500 I want you to
spend that and I want to know what you
buy there are still hot topics yeah
they're out there actually that we did
it wit listen we are very generous here
at the HD podcasts we did get you this
oh there's a consolation but the real
gift is the hot topic I appreciate that
no this is a kind of garbage honestly
yeah throw that all about the hot topic
but I do want you to go to hot topic and
report back and what you were able to
buy for 15 or 15 bucks no it's gonna
happen you're gonna end up going there
and spending cuz you can't buy anything
for 50 bucks kind of cursing you cursing
me - you're gonna next time you see me
I'm gonna have a bunch of invader zim
shirts
congratulations
[Music]
coming here you guys switch really fast
happy birthday dude we're doing that
button I did give him a real gift you
guys thanks to that but it's uh oh god
what I sniffed that in coming here and
finally guys to close out the show next
week remember Tuesday ela returns
episode Thursday dunkey and Lia
episode we've got a lot on deck in this
is a big moment for you talk about a Bar
Mitzvah this is when you become a man
this is when you become initiated and to
our little clan here
so in are you ready to give this is
Skippy's belly button lint collection
stay awake during the meeting pills what
the [ __ ] has he been eating I was
looking at that too it's 1 to 2 for
regular meetings 2 to 4 forward
conferences 8 to 10 for dry high council
night the [ __ ] are they feeding him what
the [ __ ] this is like Mormon medicine I
think it's candy cuz it says $1 79 cents
well that's a little strange I have to
say regardless Ian go ahead and have to
really I don't know you don't have to do
anything you don't want to in but now I
kind of weirdly want to cuz if you want
up you want to be one of us I guess so
yeah i guess i'll do it i guess i'll
smell it okay give it a strong with wow
that was a strong one it's got a oaky
describe oke Oke maybe i'm detecting
pomegranate right no it smells like an
old mattress like a really old mat like
like you as you're walking down the
street and i say that and you see it on
the side of the road to me it's so much
worse than that like there's such a must
it's on leave of worse than the street
managers bro it's like a it's like a
street mattress black hole
like if it was consolidated until like a
marble all of its smell
they like compress there's like little
pubic hairs in it oh that's great well
I'll tell you what we're gonna wrap this
and [ __ ] blaze it someday and I want
you to be the first one to hit it I
don't and I was doing maybe it's a
regenerative thing maybe stuff how like
foreskin yeah you want to try it you
want to eat something I don't want to
eat
idea love you in here we love dan the
birthday boy shoutout to ela who's back
shut off to Sarah who played valiantly
and won and of course the real MVP whom
we all love and of course the pret the
inheritor bows in the house Papa John's
out bow is it doesn't have fuzz in the
house with that being said guys thank
you so much for watching we will see you
on Tuesday Thursday I hope you guys have
a great great weekend and I wish you all
the very very best
[Music]
you can cut it down you can look in the
back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]